THE TALIBAN HAS FORMED A NEW
GOVERNMENT IN AFGHANISTAN AND A
BIG SURPRISE, IT IS FILLED WITH
TERRORISTS.
SORRY, NOT A SINGLE FEMALE AMONG
THEM.
IT'S ALL SEXIST.
THEIR INCOMING CABINET INCLUDES
4G BODIES RELEASED FROM GITMO BY
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION IN
EXCHANGE FOR THE U.S. ARMY
SERGEANT BILL BERGDAHL BACK IN
2018.
>> MAYBE THEY WERE PICKED UP IN
AFGHANISTAN BUT THEY WERE PICKED
UP ALL OVER THE WORLD.
THEY ARE TERRORISTS AND ENEMY
COMBATANTS ARE NOT PRISONERS OF
WAR.
>> Greg: AND SO YOU HAVE A
CATCH AND RELEASE GAME WITH
MANIACS, IT'S OKAY TO LET THEM
GO BECAUSE THEY WILL COME BACK.
IT'S AWFULLY INSANE.
WHO IS NOT GORA GORGEOUS TRUTH
TELLER?
THEN THERE'S THE TALIBAN'S NEW
INTERIOR MINISTER WHO WAS WANTED
BY THE FBI WITH A $10 MILLION
BOUNTY ON HIS HEAD AND HE'S SAID
TO BE HOLDING LEAST ONE AMERICAN
HOSTAGE.
AND THIS, THERE WAS NO HOSTAGE
LIKE SITUATION STOPPING THEM
FROM LEAVING.
ANTHONY LINCOLN IS NOW CHANGING
HIS TUNE.
>> AS OF NOW THE TALIBAN ARE NOT
PERMITTING THE CHARTER FLIGHTS
TO THE PARK.
THEY CLAIMED THAT SOME OF THE
PASTORS DO NOT HAVE THE REQUIRED
DOCUMENTATION.
BOTH WHITES NEED TO BE ABLE TO
DEPART.
WE WILL WORK EVERY DAY TO MAKE
SURE THAT THEY ARE ABLE TO DO
THAT.
WE WILL CONTINUE TO PRESS THE
TALIBAN TO ALLOW THE TARTARUS TO
LEAVE.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW DANA, I LOVE
HOW THE STATE DEPARTMENT WAS
SURPRISED AND DISMAYED THAT IT
WAS AN ALL-MALE CABINET.
IT WAS LIKE THEY EXPECTED A
BROCHURE ON DIVERSITY FROM A
LOCAL COLLEGE.
>> Dana: AND THE STATEMENT
THAT SAID WE ARE VERY
DISAPPOINTED, WE ARE VERY
CONCERNED.
LIKE STRONG LETTER TO FOLLOW.
I GUESS THEY THOUGHT THEY WERE
GOING TO BE MORE FRIENDLY, LESS
LIKE GETTING HIGH ON YOUR OWN
SUPPLY IF YOU KNOW WHAT I MEAN.
>> Greg: I BET YOU DO KNOW
WHAT YOU MEAN, DANA.
>> Dana: YOU SAID YESTERDAY WE
HAVE TO BAN THE PHRASE, THE
WORLD IS WATCHING.
THE WORLD IS AVERTING HIS EYES,
AND WHEN THESE CHARACTERS, NOT
ONLY DO THEY HAVE THE DETAINEES
FROM THE BOW BERGDAHL EXCHANGE,
BUT THEY'VE INVITED SOME
COUNTRIES TO THE CEREMONY.
THE COUNTRIES ARE RUSSIA, CHINA
AND IRAN.
SO YEAH, THAT'S HAPPENING.
>> WE WEREN'T EVEN ASKED.
>> Dana: I ALSO FEEL LIKE
THERE'S BEEN SOME SEMANTICS OVER
THE HOSTAGE AND AT THIS POINT
THERE ARE PEOPLE THAT CAN COME
TO AMERICA, THEY HAVE GOT THEIR
PAPERWORK, THERE MIGHT BE
AMERICAN CITIZENS AMONGST THE
GROUP ALONG WITH PEOPLE WHO
HELPED AMERICANS ON THE TALIBAN
WILL LET THEM GO.
TO ME, YOU LOOK UP IN WEBSTER'S
AND THAT'S THE DEFINITION.
I THINK HE IS A SOFT-SPOKEN
PERSON.
IT WOULD BE NICE TO SEE A LITTLE
FIRE AND A LITTLE DETERMINATION
THAT YES, WE ARE GOING TO GET
THE PEOPLE BACK.
>> Greg: THEY SEEM LIKE THEY
DON'T KNOW WHAT TO DO.
THEY ARE IN A QUAGMIRE WHICH IS
A WORD I JUST CAME UP WITH.
JESSICA I NOTICED IN THE NEW
CABINET THERE IS NOT A SINGLE
TRANS INDIVIDUAL.
WHAT DO YOU SAY ABOUT THIS?
>> YOU KNOW WHEN THERE IS A NEW
ADMINISTRATION THAT COMES IN BUT
THERE IS NOT ACTUALLY A NEW
ADMINISTRATION BECAUSE THEY ARE
HOLDOVERS AND THIS IS LIKE THE
GREATEST HITS OF TERRORISTS FROM
THE 1990.
LIKE PEOPLE WHO WENT INTO THE
BUNKER IS ESSENTIALLY FOR A 20
OR 30 YEARS AND NOW THEY ARE
BACK IN THEIR IN PROMINENT
POSITIONS.
DANA, YOU REFERENCED THE
INAUGURATION.
THE REST OF THE WORLD CAN'T COME
BECAUSE WE WILL BE THINKING
ABOUT THE LIVES THAT WE LOST ON
9/11 OR DOING IT ON 9/11 WHICH
IS PROBABLY THE GREATEST TROLL
OF ALL TIME, AS WERE SITTING
HERE HAVING A SOMBER MOMENT AS
OUR ALLIES WHO WENT TO WAR WITH
US OVER WHAT HAPPENED AND WHEN
WE LOST 3,000 PLUS AMERICANS AND
ONE DAY, THEN OBVIOUSLY THEY ARE
COUNTLESS LIVES SINCE THEN.
IT'S TERRIBLE.
IT'S A HARD-LINER GOVERNMENT AND
THE PEOPLE ARE SITTING ON THESE
PLAINS.
LIKE WHAT DO YOU DO?
THEY ARE LYING THAT THEY DON'T
HAVE THE RIGHT PAPERWORK, NO ONE
GOT ON THOSE FLIGHTS WITHOUT IT
BUT IT'S GOVERNMENT PLANS AND
THEN, $750,000 PER PLANE,
COULDN'T GET THEM OFF THE GROUND
A COUPLE DAYS AGO.
IT'S REALLY DIPLOMATIC DISASTER
AT THIS POINT.
>> Greg: IT'S BEYOND BELIEF.
WHEN YOU THINK ABOUT BOWE
BERGDAHL, WE KNEW THAT WAS GOING
TO HAPPEN AND I WAS HAPPENING,
AND THEY ARE IN CHARGE.
>> Dagen: MAYBE I SHOULDN'T BE
SURPRISED BY THE LANGUAGE THAT
20 BLANK AND IS USING, BUT THEY
WERE DISMAYED ABOUT THE TALIBAN
THE INTERIM GOVERNMENT WITH AN
INCLUSIVE, AND HE'S CALLING
THEM, THEY HAVE CHALLENGING
TRACK RECORDS.
LISTEN, THE TALIBAN IS HORRIBLE
AND EVIL AND THEY WILL ALWAYS BE
HORRIBLE AND EVIL, THERE'S NO
BORN-AGAIN TALIBAN.
AND THAT'S WHO WE JUST
SURRENDERED TO.
WITH THE GREATEST DISHONOR, AND
NOW PUTTING OUR AMERICANS AND
OUR ALLIES IN THE GREATEST
DANGER, EVEN HERE AT HOME.
IN IN TERMS OF THE LANGUAGE THIS
GOES TO WHAT CARTER DID WITH THE
SOVIET UNION AND CLINTON DID IT
WITH AL QAEDA AND OBAMA DID IT
WITH IRAN.
THEY ACT LIKE, WELL, IF WE MAY
BE HOPE AND NOT PRAY BECAUSE
THAT'S EVIL, RIGHT?
THEY JUST EVOLVE INTO GOOD
DEMOCRATS.
IF YOU TREAT THEM SAY WITH IRAN,
IF YOU TREAT THEM LIKE A NORMAL
WESTERN GOVERNMENT, IF YOU TREAT
THEM LIKE BRITAIN THAN IT WILL
BE BRITAIN AND IT JUST DOESN'T
HAPPEN.
YOU ALWAYS TALK ABOUT THE
REDNECKS AND THE RUBES AND THE
HAYSEEDS WITH LOVE, BUT WE KNOW
TOP LOOKING AT A ROGUE OR
REPROBATE YOU CAN'T TREAT THEM
LIKE A NORMAL DUTY BECAUSE THEY
WILL COME AT YOU AND THEY WILL
STEAL FROM YOU BECAUSE THEY ARE
A ROGUE AND A REPROBATE.
THESE PEOPLE IN THE BIDEN
ADMINISTRATION DON'T SEEM TO
KNOW THAT ABOUT A TERRORIST
ORGANIZATION.
>> Greg: IT'S LIKE DATING
SOMEBODY, YOU CAN'T CHANGE THEM.
THEY WILL BE A TERRORIST NO
MATTER WHAT.
I TOLD YOU THAT'S THE TALIBAN
ALSO BAND SPORTS FOR GIRLS AND
YOU SAID NOW THAT SOMETHING YOU
COULD GET BEHIND.
>> Jesse: [LAUGHS]
WHICH SPORTS?
I THINK THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
PLAY SPORTS, NOT ALL.
IF I COULD GO BACK IN TIME TO
CHANGE ONE THING WHAT DO YOU
THINK THAT WOULD BE?
I'LL ANSWER IT FOR YOU.
ALL TIME, I WOULD GO BACK IN
TIME AND MAKE SURE THAT
BARACK OBAMA WAS NEVER
PRESIDENT.
I DON'T KNOW HOW I WOULD DO IT,
BUT HERE'S WHY.
IT'S LIKE, YOU KILL TWO BIRDS
WITH ONE STONE BECAUSE IF BARACK
WASN'T PRESIDENT, THEN JOE BIDEN
WOULDN'T BE PRESIDENT.
BUTTERFLY EFFECT.
THE BOOK WAS BETTER THAN THE
MOVIE.
THINK ABOUT WHAT BARACK OBAMA
DID IN AFGHANISTAN.
EVEN I CAN'T TAKE IT SERIOUSLY
[LAUGHS]
MY FRIENDS BROTHER PRODUCED THE
MOVIE.
[LAUGHS]
HE IS THE ONE THAT STARTS
100,000 TROOPS INTO AFGHANISTAN
AND HE IS THE ONE THAT NATION
BUILT.
HE'S THE ONE THAT TRAINED THE
AFGHAN ARMY.
HE WAS THE ONE WHO GOT
HOODWINKED BY THE PAKISTANIS.
THAT BIN LADEN WAS JUST HIDING
THERE IN PLAIN SIGHT.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT TOLD OF SOME
OF THIS GREAT PROGRESS THERE
THAT WAS A MIRAGE.
HE WAS THE ONE THAT TRADED FIVE
TALIBAN COMMANDERS FOR A
DESERTER.
IN FOUR OF THEM ARE NOW BACK.
I DON'T KNOW WHAT THE OTHER ONE
IS DOING.
HE'S LIKE ASSISTANT TO THE
REGIONAL COMMANDER IN
AFGHANISTAN.
AND BARACK OBAMA WAS SUPPOSED TO
BE THE SMART ONE.
NEVER JOE BIDEN WAS THE JOKE,
AND NOW THE JOKE IS THE
PRESIDENT, THE JOKES ON US.
HOW STUPID DO THE FEDS LOOK?
THE FEDS PUT TRUMP CAMPAIGN
OFFICIALS BEHIND BARS, AND THEN
THEY RELEASED THE TALIBAN.
THE FEDS FRAMED CARTER PAGE FOR
COLLUDING WITH THE RUSSIANS YET
THE FBI'S MOST WANTED TERRORIST
IN AFGHANISTAN IS COLLUDING WITH
AL QAEDA.
HIS HOLDING AMERICAN CITIZEN
HOSTAGE AND JOE BIDEN WOULDN'T
EVEN CALL HIM THE ENEMY.
SO THAT THEY ARE NOW UPSET
THERE'S NO WOMEN IN THE
GOVERNMENT.
IT'S AN ONION ARTICLE.
JOE BIDEN THINKS HE CAN ME, TOO
THE TALIBAN.
THEY DON'T HAVE WOMEN IN THE
TALIBAN.
I MEAN LINCOLN, ANTHONY, WHERE
IS THE H?
INSTEAD OF BEING SO CONCERNED
ABOUT THE GENDER OF THE TELE-
BAND CABINET, BE CONCERNED ABOUT
STRANDED AMERICANS.
>> Greg: YOU KNOW, BIDEN
DOESN'T LIKE THE TALIBAN AND
BECAUSE OF HARD TO SNIFF HERE
UNDER A BURQA.
>> Jessica: I KNOW WE HAVE
LIMITED TIME, THAT WASN'T WHAT I
WAS LOOKING FOR, AND A LOT OF
STUFF JUST FLEW OUT OF JESSE'S
MOUTH.
IF THAT WOULD BE THE FIRST
THING, THE SEARCH IS WIDELY
LOOKED UPON IN ALL POLITICAL
CIRCLES AS BEING ONE OF THE MOST
SUCCESSFUL PARTS ACTUALLY OF THE
WAR ON TERROR.
>> Greg: AND IRAQ, NOT LESS
NECESSARILY IN AFGHANISTAN.
B5 WE WILL GET OTHER PEOPLE IN
THE SHOW TO TALK ABOUT THAT.
WE HAVE TO GO BUT EVERYTHING YOU
SA